what am I doing here what am what am i
what do we got okay this is weird
[Music]
hey what is going on yet yeah yeah
currently toad [ __ ] yes I know it's
been a really long time and this video
is going to be interesting because I'm
gonna give you insight about what I've
been doing in the past year and a half
it's a long one
but hold your britches [ __ ] so I think
you all deserve an explanation for the
spotty uploads and my absence for the
past three and a half months or so this
explanation isn't something as simple as
I just needed a break it kind of goes
deeper into that and I I wanted to relay
this message to you guys in this video
so in the past year I have been
re-evaluating my life and it has not
been easy so as all of you may or may
not know I worked on a film project
called Luke the film and it got into
Sundance we actually won an award at
Sundance and on top of that we sold the
film and it did a theater run for about
three months what I experienced with
that film creating it and just being a
huge part of something that was really
important to me that was a culmination
of all my hard work and efforts was the
highlight of my life now what I didn't
think about after the film was over was
what next justin chon who wrote this
directed and produced it you know he he
kind of opened up my eyes to a world
that I didn't expect and kind of like
unlock the a certain type of potential
in me that I didn't know I had I think
the problem with that was that after the
film was over I was left questioning my
purpose it's like okay you did this
project you did the film I you didn't
expect to go to Sundance and it did you
didn't expect to go to theaters and it
did so so what next
but what's your next step after this and
I was trying to answer that question and
I I couldn't do it I can't it was blank
so for the past year or so I made even a
year and a half after the film was done
I have been trying to find my reason to
wake up you know aside from waking up
and making a paycheck and just uploading
videos on YouTube like what do you want
to do next like what are your goals and
I know it's been a long time since you
guys seen a video from me and you guys
are probably a little bit upset about
that and for those of you who left
before I can upload this video you
Chauncy ass mother I'm Kang that's my B
who's Mari I'll take responsibility and
I said this before in a previous video
just because a lot of these youtubers
and social media influencers want you to
believe that their life is perfect it
doesn't necessarily mean that it's true
look if you are even slightly insightful
you should know by now that a majority
of that [ __ ] is a facade the only
problem is with me I can't I can't lie
to myself you know and some of you out
there might be watching this video and
like oh my god this degree which real
real if you think I'm being too real
with you on any idea how I talk to
myself
you [ __ ] ass [ __ ] you know walking
around aimlessly and how I felt about my
life started to leak into everything
that I was doing my personal life how I
was treating other people and especially
how I was treating myself so the first
thing that I had to do in order to fix
this problem was I had to learn how to
take responsibility for what was
happening to me and learn to take these
problems one step at a time I'm not sure
if any of you out there can relate to
this but you guys ever feel like you're
trying to do or be so many things at
once you just end up not doing anything
at all I guess if I were to explain it
it's kind of like you're running a
million miles a day right with your head
down not being aware of your
surroundings and when you finally look
up you realize you just ended up back at
the same place because you were just
running in circles you kind of feel
defeated so you end up feeling like
you're working hard all the time but you
haven't really done [ __ ] if that if that
even makes sense to you you know I
wanted to be an actor I was getting into
auditions I was working on my channel
and then on top of that a new Food Show
trying to pitch a new television show
trying to write a new movie and the list
goes on and on and on and on I was
opening up food businesses but when you
overwhelm yourself with a lot of these
different things what ends up happening
is that you split yourself up into so
many different things that nothing
really ever gets the attention that it
deserves and so because I realized this
I decided to strip everything away from
me everything that I was doing that I
was trying to split my time into and
that included YouTube and the next step
after taking everything away I decided
to add the things that are important to
me one at a time and the first thing
that I had to focus on that is a
foundation of Who I am as a person and
if I want to continue in being this
space or just living in general was to
get my health back so during this weird
state after the film and trying to
collect and find myself you know that
[ __ ] term I gained a [ __ ] ton of
weight and I'm pretty sure you guys
noticed it too because I read in a
couple of comments but in my mind I was
like you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about all the good you're so
funny when you're so out of shape but
your self-esteem is so damn high the
only thing you see in the mirror is a
bird dirt my self-esteem game is strong
son I would gain 40 pounds
the mirror said [ __ ] like oh I look back
in it now and I cracked the [ __ ] up
because I was getting so fat and my
shirts were fitting like a [ __ ] wet
suit but immediately I knew what the
problem was my dryer I don't know why we
fat people always do that [ __ ] it's
never our life choices it's it's always
the dryer and that the washer and dryer
has some magical powers against me only
[ __ ] what's up Merlin abracadabra
shrieked my shirt against [ __ ] oh my
god I can't breathe this you're so tight
got so bad at a certain point I started
blaming the t-shirt company and [ __ ] oh
I'm about to send this email out dear
change fat lives matter now I don't know
if you all can tell but in the past 3
months I have lost a total of 30 pounds
30 pounds is not where this goal is
going to end for me clearly I'm still on
the bigger size but I still have about
28 more pounds to lose to be honest with
you I would not have been able to do
this if I didn't stop take a second to
breathe and realize that I was trying to
do too many things at once personally I
had to learn how to tackle my problems
one at a time and that was probably the
biggest reason why I could never lose
weight or even if I did lose a lot of
weight like the first time I did but it
benefit I couldn't keep it off I would
try to do things either too extreme like
powerless six seven times a week just so
I could lose weight really fast or I
just would keep making excuses for
myself because I was so busy trying to
do everything else and learning to do
one things at a time and becoming a
master of one it's not something that
was new to me I had this conversation
with myself before back in the day I
wanted to be a musician so bad but at
the same time I wanted to be a comedian
but I made that choice I decided to draw
music for a second and take it as a
hobby and just focus on comedy and if I
hadn't done that I wouldn't be here
right now now even though I still have
28 more pounds to lose
I have a grip on my health and I have a
healthy perspective about my life and
the foods that I eat and how I should
take care of my body you know so that's
why I'm back on YouTube again like I
said before I kind of want to do
anything and everything but I am gonna
go back to my
bread-and-butter which is this having
conversations and talking to you guys
whether it's like vice Kern's topics or
anything that you guys leave in the
comments below let's have a conversation
and talk about it let's just make you
laugh because at the end of the day like
I'm here for you but the biggest thing
that I want you guys to know that there
is no set schedule there's no Sunday
always at 12:00 p.m. there is only I
will upload when it feels right so what
I need you guys to do as a favor is just
to hit that notification button so you
guys know when the videos are coming out
because I am going to be putting up
content it might be two videos a week
might be once every two weeks who knows
but I will be actively creating content
but I do have a question before I sign
up you guys want to know how I lost this
thirty pounds do you guys want to know
how difficult it was how [ __ ]
mentally draining it was but at the same
time rewarding and easy at the same time
he's kind of weird maybe I will leave
that in the comments below let me know
what you guys want me to talk about and
I will see you guys next time
yeah shave those peanuts they see that's
what I'm talking about you don't say
[ __ ] like that
[Music]
you
so like dirt sideburn hey what is going
on yeah
yes sexy [ __ ] guerrillas oh that's it
yeah oh they came off a little racist
[ __ ] no I'm in silverback